one of the top analysts in all the land
college football analyst of Fox Sports
and as I mentioned Chris Brockman last
week before II introduced him he and Gus
Johnson are the tracks of my misery yes
something like that boy said they voice
tracks of my misery with the Michigan
Wolverines he's none other than Joel
cloud how are you Joel I didn't know
that this phone interview was gonna
trigger you in some way but the voice
tracks of your misery I've never quite
heard it I was in such a good mood and
now all of a sudden oh my gosh I'm so I
honestly am so scarred by the some of
these experiences of watching Michigan
and and of late and you and goth seem to
be in the booth every time since Fox has
only the only the best Big Ten games so
there's that it's not been good to you I
mean I think a lot listen let's start
with Michigan if you don't mind well for
me way worse than even last year I know
that the fans the Ohio State game means
more right but from my standpoint just
for a moment from an overall program I
thought last week was was the the bottom
of the barrel potentially just because
it felt so much different because they
didn't have an identity you know at
least against Ohio State last year you
could say hey one of our starting
corners was hurt they've got three guys
that ran under for fourth the NFL
Combine they've got the you know one of
the top quarterbacks in the draft like
okay we went there and we lost you know
when a [ __ ] was a little banged up so
on and so forth but last week against
Wisconsin Wisconsin literally took their
own identity what Michigan has built
itself under under Harbaugh and just
smashed him with it and to me sitting up
in the booth I was like man this this is
a lower point than losing to Ohio State
last year you know what I'm retort las'
Joel I I don't even I don't I don't know
how to say what you just said was
inaccurate in any way and you didn't
even mention the fact it was coming off
a bye week that that was a week's extra
week's worth of preparation before that
before which is not good and I tell you
there's no element to that team that you
can say like well at least they've got
this or that that are
they're playing well they they were bad
in every single phase and I think that
the more troubling part and the reason
that I just don't see them getting out
of this is the offensive line was awful
you know and so that's that's a that's a
troubling aspect of all of this is is
that their offensive line which I
thought was going to be one of the
better offensive lines in the entire
conference isn't even close and they
were playing really really poorly and
those quarterbacks had no chance in the
pocket well thanks for coming on Joel we
appreciate your time I mean you're in
Oklahoma you're gonna see Jalen Hertz
this week and the reason why I met up
just before we get dive deeper into him
and Oklahoma is is Justin fields goes
from Georgia to Ohio State we all know
where Hertz came from before showing up
in Oklahoma Michigan goes and grabs Shay
Patterson from Ole Miss and that hasn't
even come close to working out as well
as the two previous instances is it the
offensive line is it what is it just
before we move on because that's the
question I'm getting from so many of my
fellow alums and Friends is is the
quarterback the issue that Harbaugh just
doesn't have one and still hasn't really
well I think it's it's probably it's
probably way too easy
or maybe lazy to just blame it on the
quarterback I think Shay has played well
at times and he wasn't really a great
fit for the pro style and now this year
I don't think that the team and the
philosophy and the identity is a great
fit for Josh Gattis in this offense I
think that they have a clear lack of
understanding as a from a player base of
how to run this offense efficiently and
and the offensive line certainly has
been in this philosophical change
they're the ones that I think have been
most hurt because they just don't play
with the same energy the same discipline
the same detail that they were able to
play with in years prior so in years
prior they had a system that had a real
inability to beat teams that they were
overmatched by or come back if they had
a deficit you know so that was a system
issue they just had a hard time throwing
the football in a drop back mode
it wasn't what the system was built for
so they go to this speed in space they
bring in Josh Gattis they changed their
philosophy and yet what they have lost
is the ability to control the game on
the ground to have the ability to throw
a play-action pass and so now they just
don't have an identity from a place
election standpoint from a toughness
mentality and they puts the chips right
into the middle of the table and it was
kind of boom or bust and it's gone bust
so far so I think it's probably more
holistic rich than it is just about the
quarterback because even when Dillon
McCaffrey went into the game and he's a
really talented player you got all these
quarterbacks there they're talented guys
but they were getting snatched on every
single passing attempt Wisconsin was
putting pressure with three guys four
guys
the offensive line could not do anything
to slow down that rush well it's
interesting you use a word holistic
because that's the type of drugs I've
been using and get through some of these
games lately Jay so it kind of we kind
of match up right there Joel cloud here
on the Rich Eisen show okay so you Gus
and Jenny Taft are in the Heartland
Texas Tech and Oklahoma Jalen Hertz is
just truly one of the most remarkable
stories in all the land he has been
nothing short of dynamite what young man
have you found showing up there in
Oklahoma fresh out of Alabama I think
he's one of the most mature players that
I've ever been around
at this stage and and he has a unique
understanding of his role not only here
at Oklahoma but within college football
and in this day and age of kids that
quite frankly are really immature
because of the way that they're
recruited and then the ability to
transfer at any time
he's navigated this period as as well as
anybody to the point where he's a fan
favorite all over the country because of
his team person mentality kind of doing
it the right way graduates before you
now he's here and he's having a lot of
success and I got to tell you the
biggest difference from me is when he
was playing at Alabama they were still
running a system and having a philosophy
that was hey quarterback don't hurt us
you know play safe don't turn the ball
over manage the game and we're going to
with our running game to our defense and
and that was kind of the philosophy when
he was playing there and then all the
sudden they changed that philosophy and
they've come and gone towards - and they
went towards the wide open offense last
year more specifically they threw 52
touchdown passes as a program last year
which led the country so they clearly
had a philosophical change with some of
their wide receivers and quarterback
that they had I think he felt like he
never got a chance to play in that
offense and to really cut it loose so
one of the things Lincoln Riley has done
with Jalen ever since he got here on
campus as they've worked more on getting
him out of the game management mode and
into the playmaker mode go play carefree
cut it loose get the ball down the field
you know when you want to take off take
off you can be a playmaker for us and
not just a game manager for us now while
a quarterback has to manage the game in
and of playing the position again the
freedom with which he plays is very
different just to give you an idea here
in terms of yards per attempt he leads
the country rich at over 14 yards per
attempt that's number two yards more Wow
than the number two player in the
country which is Jill burrow at LSU over
two yards at Bama jaylen hurts yards per
attempt was seven point nine so he's
almost doubling what he was at Alabama
and I think it's more of a philosophy
it's more of a freedom with which he
plays and it's also the ability of his
play caller Lincoln Riley to get
beneficial matchups in space and
allowing him to make those plays down
down the field but it's not just a
bility to throw which i think is really
good he also and I know this is heavy
statistics here but he also averages
over 12 and a half yards every time he
has the ball whether it's a pass or a
rush that's the best in the country
12 and a half yards every time he either
throws it or runs it he is a dynamo
right now in college football and it's
the vote took place today he would be
the Heisman Trophy winner yeah I mean
you're not you you you can't argue with
that Joel Klein Fox Sports he's gonna
call that Oklahoma Texas Tech game I
have a pen I have a Sharpie here
should I go get a pencil and the reason
why I asked that is which would I use to
put Oklahoma versus Alabama and the
first national championship semifinal
game this this fall wouldn't it be
amazing I mean wouldn't it be amazing
tell me how that doesn't happen then
well I think that the the defense for
Oklahoma can still be a concern and Sam
Mellinger is throwing the ball as well
as anybody out there and so their
ability to beat Texas I think is still a
coin flip you know and they're probably
gonna have to play them twice so I you
know I don't know if you can just
absolutely shoe-in Oklahoma into the
playoff Ohio State looks really good
right now I actually think that there's
more great teams this year than we've
seen over the last four or five years
came into the year thinking it was just
gonna be Clemson in Alabama and then
they would just play for the national
championship but now when you when I
look around you know
LSU Georgia Ohio State Oklahoma
Wisconsin all these teams look like they
can play at the top echelon in college
football maybe even Texas even after
that loss to LSU so I don't think you
can just pencil or pen in Oklahoma but I
think everybody rich would love to see
Jalen Hurd's play in stout him I mean
football playoff but in a semifinal you
know what I mean like that's the two
versus three seed situation I could see
that right now plain as day and it's not
even October yet Joel cloud here on the
Rich Eisen show so last year Texas Tech
Oklahoma interestingly enough that was
the one matchup where Kliff Kingsbury
coach of Texas Tech lets it drop hey if
I had the first overall pick in the
draft I would take Oklahoma Skylar
Marian never haha and then guess what
happened and we all know what happened
at the top of that draft Joel and then a
couple pics later Daniel Jones is
selected by the New York Football Giants
our that day in person in Nashville who
was so very strong in in saying how that
was the worst pick maybe the Giants have
ever had and I think you said that
they'd set the franchise back is what I
think I heard that you
okay so you can see by my phrasing my
hands right now in my hotel that was me
now is most people Joey let me let me
explain let me explain go forth he can
work out and and be a really good player
and while what I said about setting the
franchise back might not be true it can
still be the wrong selection I'm not
trying to die on the sword here that's a
yes there there's a combination of
player and value that makes a pick a
great pick I think you understand where
I'm going here if you could have gotten
Daniel Jones at 17 then selecting him
where you did is is the wrong pick cause
you could have gotten the correct value
at that they believe it was the sixth
pick yes so I'm wrong let me just state
by saying like hey I was wrong about
down in Daniel jumped I thought he had a
ceiling and and that he was basically at
his ceiling and that it wasn't gonna
work out based on what I had seen it do
I was dead wrong he's played amazing and
I'll be the first to eat that crow
however the value of where you select
for instance I know that this is gonna
sound insane if you go back to the Tom
Brady draft you don't draft him number
one why because you can get him with the
199 pick right right so like like
there's a valuation that has to take
place in order to select players and
build your roster to the best possible
way now if it works out it's gonna work
out and and good for them but it could
have worked out later in that first
round and if they would have gotten some
more help for their roster at six that
would have been more advantageous again
love preface I was wrong however when it
comes to the valuation there's still an
element of did you select them in the
right spot what do you think of Murray's
first two games then Jill I think Tyler
has been really good I think that that
roster is
really bad but there are times when he
cuts it loose when he came back and tied
the game against the Lions and and so on
he's looked the part and I think that's
what all of us are waiting to see is he
gonna make some mistakes yes is it a bad
roster yes is he also breaking in a
brand new head coach that everyone has
maybe more questions than him about yes
so is it going to look amazing right
away no but I think that we've seen
enough to say like okay like this can
work his passing acumen his ability to
be quick in space avoid big hits all of
those things are absolutely still true
any surprise that Haskins hasn't even
gotten a sniff to the point where case
Kingdom's in a walking boot in Jay
Gruden still won't say if Haskins is
starter this week yes and actually I've
dug around and tried to get a sense of
what's going on there and and I have I
have pretty good Intel that the coaching
staff was never really on board with the
selection and that was more of a front
office selection and so there's a there
is a riff right now of like who the
front office wants to play and who the
coaching staff wants to play so that's
not a good situation right now in
Washington no not there not on the same
page no kidding so yeah are you a
whistle blower
is there a whistle blower in Washington
DC from from from Virginia triggered by
hearing my voice but let's not trigger
everything nice nice so really so that
you're here and yeah that that's
absolutely what I've been hearing from
some people close and and within the
organization is that in particular back
you know when the selection took place
that there was some folded arms on one
side kind of like okay this isn't what
we want to do but we'll do it well I'm
sure those folded arms are not Dan
Snyder's you know no right no no I I'm
interested to see what its what it's
going to look like over the next few
games because at this point I mean what
do they have to lose man so
and Dewayne Haskins are shaking your
heads
when Daniel Jones gets picked by the
Giants and then Haskins that gets picked
by Washington and half the the draft
room is shaking its heads is what you're
saying yes from what I understand right
they never they never thought that
Dewayne was gonna be available so so the
situation was not thoroughly vetted
between some of the decision makers and
the coaching staff and so once the
daniel Jones pick happened it kind of
threw everything into motion and and one
side started saying oh this is great we
thought he wasn't going to be available
now we can take him and the other side
was saying well we didn't want him
anyways Joel that's some food for
thought to say the least and before I
let you go one last thing on Daniel
Jones asked this of Bruce Feldman your
colleague at Fox Sports college football
yesterday in your evaluation of daniel
Jones you never once heard the nickname
Danny dimes right not even a single time
no right no I not never one not one not
from the campus not from his not from
his side not from anybody not a scout
not a single soul referred to him as
Danny dimes correct nope never heard
Danny dimes my god
I cannot confirm that report ok that I
don't even I I like that nickname less
than your evaluation of him first blush
Joel that's how much I dislike that
nickname the best man you did you did
man you owned it you raised your hand in
your hotel room and we're gonna take
your word for it that you did thanks for
send our best to Gus tell them tell them
well you know so do you have any more
Michigan games on the schedule right now
Nick next week you've got Michigan Iowa
that's right oh I've got oh my god get
the holistic
see I need all of that ready oh my gosh
take care of yourself job well I'll be
I'll be listening to you next week
thanks for the call Joel klutz
Joel class on Twitter and at Joel
underscore clot on instagram right here
on the Rich Eisen show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app